bienvenue sur cette nouvelle vidéo de
cette chaîne la société ecc alors
aujourd'hui j'ai l'occasion
[Musique]
l'hypothèse de pierre bourdieu et donc
par rapport à notre position sociale
nous allons choisir nous allons préféré
certaines choses plutôt que d'autres et
les choses qui seront choisis par les
classes supérieures seront les choses
qui seront considérés dans une société
comme légitime
les choses choisi par les classes plus
populaires ou apprécié par les classes
populaires seront vus comme des goûts
jules hier qu'ils ne sont pas dignes
d'être acceptée comme le goût
dans sa quintessence même dans sa plus
parfaite expression et si le travail de
bien aux dieux commence par la musique
c'est pas anodin puisque pierre bourdieu
nous dit à la page 17 de son
introduction la musique et l'art pur par
excellence elle ne dit rien et n'a rien
à dire donc les choix qui vont être
opérées par les différents individus qui
participent à lenquête seront vraiment
des choix qui seront pure qui seront
vraiment
b basé sur leurs goûts et non pas sur
d'un texte ou ou des choses comme celles
là donc c'est vraiment la forme que biz
pierre bonneau étant donné que les
classes supérieures on choisir un style
de musique ce style de musique là qui
sera considéré comme le plus légitime
comme porteur du bon goût le beau danube
bleu étant vu comme un choix plus juliet
roux quelque chose pour un peu populaire
à ce sujet je vous propose une vidéo que
j'avais fait précédemment sur la
violence symbolique qui nous permet de
comprendre comment ce mécanisme
fonctionne
bon
[Musique]
e